Merry Christmas reject nation we bring
you the review of the movie that
everyone seen everyone has tuned in for
the 10 million dollar opening of the
greatest showman on earth yeah we're
putting up our review today guy keep
something in mind with us ok we saw us a
couple weeks ago and then the embargo
wasn't gonna live for a couple weeks so
we're like we'll just shoot it a little
bit later so we might have forgotten
some stuff but I remember my overall
opinion in feelings when this movie
ended yeah I remember pretty much how I
felt
yeah so that's what we're gonna share
with you guys today so the greatest
showman on earth is the great showman
the greatest showman on earth know the
greatest show on earth the greatest
showman
the greatest showman this is the story
of PT Barnum who created the
entertainment industry you created the
circus or the freak shows and everything
we really want to do a segment called
trailers revisited cuz if we were
looking at the trailer again to refresh
our mind and the trailer might give you
the impression that it's a story about
guide down-on-his-luck who decides to
come up with this circus show and it's
about the freaks and the relationship
that it has with the world how
revolutionized things when that's not
really with the movies up done okay yeah
the first half makes me think it is but
without the but with the focus
distributed in places that are mostly
huge and focuses mainly PT Barnum and
his story of success and the lessons
he's learned along the way of greed and
power all those fun cliches those films
with things that people give into in the
struggle with starting a big old
business this film is filled with
ridiculous amounts of cliches however I
gotta tell you guys as a family film I
really enjoyed it honestly I did I
teared up a couple times I'm a sucker
for stories about dads husband's life
learning lessons yeah I'm a sucker for
stories like that you gotta keep that in
mind as I'm
talking about this film because lawless
cheesy while it's corny and while it's
cliche I feel like the messages are
still good they're still relevant and
there's a few dance numbers and musical
numbers in here that I really quite
enjoyed Hugh Jackman's performance is
really solid he carries this film yeah
when it comes to this movie for me I'm
kind of in a similar boat as you I
thought last I checked this had like a
51% of Rotten Tomatoes and this is one
of those movies that I think kind of
epitomizes the 50% range because as a
film there are lots of things you can
complain about I mean they don't make
very much use of PT Barnum's actual life
no and so you get kind of a pretty
familiar story of success with some
circus trappings but what really makes
this movie unique to me is the feeling
that it gave yes a lot of heart this
movie has it's not overly complex or
challenging but it did make me feel
joyous it did wrap me up in the
production value of everything and
everything is good-natured enough and
the performances are all good enough
that I did really enjoy my time even
though as a film there are a lot of
things that could be much better it's a
little bit clustered there's a lot of
story in this one movie because you got
Hugh Jackman's relationship with his
wife Michele Williams his kids the story
of the circus the story of the freaks
the story of Zac Efron and his
relationship with one of the freaks and
then Zac Efron's relationship with his
parents a whole bunch of story in this
one movie so it's a little over
convoluted at the same time though I
think the film specs a delightful tone
it's a delightful movie and a subplot
where Barnum goes off and has a
sidequest with an is yeah there's a
certain type of awe behind it were so
nice to see a musical that's not shot by
Rob Marshall yeah for once because I did
think that the way they shot this was
punch here there was some cool some cool
shots in this movie yeah another cool
shot yeah where they really capitalize
on the dancing and the choreography but
also they bother to you know compose the
shots and there are some numbers that
really sing as parts of a movie yeah
there are some songs in here that are
really damn good the highlight to me is
the first song with Zac Efron and Hugh
Jackman yeah in the bar yeah they're
drinking a bar they're taking shots or
conducting business but it's all in a
musical number and that to me is my
favorite kind of musical number where
it's progressing a plot it's a carrot
Arsene but it's also a really damn good
song and some good choreography at the
same time the same cannot be said for
all of the musical numbers there are
some musical numbers in here that I felt
were a little unnecessary there are some
musical numbers in here where they're
like this sounds a lot like the other
songs we've already heard it has this
sort how'd you put it it has it's kind
of like pop vibe to it part of my
trouble with this as a musical is that
most of the music and the dance
choreography are very modern very poppy
very pronounced that way very
melodically pop-oriented and like it's
really well choreographed but it also
doesn't always compliment this story it
doesn't always compliment the world and
the time were in sometimes mixing in
modern day musical numbers like a Moulin
Rouge or even some music of something
like a night stale who does work when
you implement that modern effect here
there are times where it's just kind of
distracting well because it's only the
style it's not like we're making a point
of being an Akron it's like this is the
only element that's very modern yeah and
so that makes it at least for me that
sometimes it works and sometimes it
doesn't and I don't think all the songs
are great in this there's a lot of stuff
I don't remember at all but there are
some some good musical moments yeah I'm
gonna say that this is devoid of good
songs and sometimes musicals have this
effect on me that could kind of
Christmas let the dog Christmas musicals
can kind of had this effect on me
occasionally where I'll listen to a song
and a musical and I don't feel like it's
necessary and it just kind of feels like
super expositional a lot of the time
when I was really pulled into the movie
it's when they're not actually singing
and dancing a lot of time when I pulled
in it's just the scenes found a lot of
that to be very effective more so than
the music sometimes when they break away
to musical numbers to get a lot of
exposition or to cover a lot of times it
make a montage out of it there's enough
in there to make it be a musical but
there's also times where I was like I
don't really need this musical number
right now yeah that's fair I mean I I do
think there are few too many songs and
there are times where you're like oh oh
we're gonna stop again yeah you know
yeah I definitely feel you there
although I don't think that it's weird
as a musical and now whatever feel
better without it or anything like that
like I liked it it's a good subject for
musical which again tears me into that
50% range where I'm like
man I wish this was a better musical but
at the same time I really enjoyed this
me yeah I feel like I'm gonna come down
there yeah a lot but Hugh Jackman's
great in this is always the the freaks
have a really good musical number in
here too that was one of the musical
numbers that really I felt the emotion
there
yeah it's rousing and you feel you
really feel forward them yeah and that's
one of the few musical numbers yeah that
pulls you into not only the glitz of it
all but the feel if there's one thing I
just really wanted a little more from
this film let's to spend more time with
the freaks to spend more time with the
circus performers because this movie
kind of forgets about it halfway through
and then it intermittently cuts back I
mean it's part of Hugh Jackman's
character to be caught up in his own
success but then at the same time it
starts missing out on that element that
probably pulled in people to wanting to
see this movie was the element of the
free shows yeah and the celebration of
you know strangeness and diversity ya
know this film is not the greatest thing
in the world
there's it's definitely flawed if you
just want to go in going like I want to
watch a delightful movie that has a good
heart
that's all this film really sets out to
do and I think it really succeeds in
that territory it's not a powerful film
but it's moving in the right places yeah
it's not a great film but it's a really
enjoyable film I thought yeah never
annoyed I was never I thought it would
be any no especially for the first
number yeah yeah and the thing is you
know once the movie does some other
things and kind of jumps you in because
I was initially taken aback by ah this
is not the kind of musical I was
expecting this to be the more I think
about it the more I just feel good
inside yeah I really had a good time I
felt good during and after and so yeah
if you're going in the movies for
Christmas or during just any part of
this holiday season here I think you'll
have a great time and everyone can enjoy
it good messages good performances all
around I think for a Christmas time too
it's a good movie it's by the closest
Christmas movie we had out in the
theaters right now yeah yeah it's like I
can't argue with any of the complaints
really I just I just
oh they're all there yeah
don't figure yes I'll give it like a 3
out of 5 stars
I'll bump it to three just because I the
feeling yeah enough that I'm like yeah I
don't think you're bad I think you could
be better all right guys well did you
see the greatest showman on earth are
you excited that Hugh Jackman is not
playing Logan anymore but it's instead
doing movies like this produced by James
Mangold subscribe to the reel rejects
click that notification bell you could
check us out on patreon it's like a
second youtube channel over there
uploading a lot right now including some
music video reactions speaking of
musicals download and follow us in the
Stardust app posting regularly over
there as well